[Musica]
[Applauso]
ricalcolo
ricalcolo ricalcola è una parola che
sento molto spesso Ieri sono arrivata
Qua da Rimini ero in macchina e per
fortuna mi è andata bene non c'erano
Troppe interruzioni un po' di traffico
ma non è anche troppo e quindi sono
stata molto fortunata molto spesso
faccio Parma Milano perché io sono di
Parma e studio a Milano ingegneria
biomedica e vado in macchina perché che
è molto più comodo i mezzi sono un po'
complicati per me ma è una storia che ci
sarà altre occasioni per raccontare
ehm quindi molte volte mi trovo in
autostrada ma l'autostrada di solito ci
metto più o meno un'ora e mezza
ehm sulla 1 spesso ci sono incidenti ci
sono lavori ed è proprio in quel momento
che mi capita di accendere il navigatore
di accendere il navigatore e controllare
quanto tempo C ci vuole per arrivare al
mio obiettivo per arrivare a
Milano quando guardo di solito se sei in
coda è perché lo accendi e il tempo va
avanti aumenta sempre di più e i
chilometri rimangono sempre fermi E qui
la freddezza del navigatore cerca di
darti un'alternativa cerca di di trovare
un'altra strada mentre noi siamo umani
non abbiamo la freddezza che può avere
la tecnologia
e quindi molte volte ci arrabbiamo
ci cerchiamo qualcosa a cui dare la
colpa ma in questo modo perdiamo tempo
soprattutto perdiamo energie quando le
potremmo impiegare nel fare nel trovare
una soluzione e ricalcola significa
trovare una strada altrove altrove è
dove io ho dovuto cercare la mia vita il
4 gennaio del
10 l'anno in cui ci sarebbero stati i
mondiali di trampolino elastico io stavo
andando in palestra a fare il mio
allenamento dopo le vacanze di Natale
e salti semplici perché ovviamente
avevamo appena iniziato fino a che
arrivano le 700 di sera l'ultimo salto
del primo allenamento io faccio un salto
indietro un salto avanti con un mezzo
giro e mi ritrovo sul telo in appoggio
sulle braccia a non sentire più le gambe
da quel
momento c'è stato un turbinio di cose
perché subito è arrivata l'ambulanza Mi
hanno immobilizzato sono stati
bravissimi Sono arrivati in ospedale e
subito esami la risonanza l'ecografia i
raggi fino a che sono arrivata nella
stanza della neurochirurgia è entrata
l'anestesista e mi ha detto Giulia non
sappiamo se ti operiamo adesso o domani
mattina io speravo lo facessero subito e
per fortuna così è stato nella mia
quotidianità ricalcolo in continuazione
molte volte troviamo un gradino molte
volte troviamo un sassolino e quando mi
trovo davanti a queste cose il cercare
una soluzione è bellissimo vi dà quella
soddisfazione quando poi riesci a
trovarla che vi auguro di provare
e altrove è dove io ho trovato il mio
futuro altrove perché altrove da una
dimensione di normalità Ma che cos'è la
normalità Per noi la normalità può
essere pensare vedere una persona che ha
due gambe due braccia che corre che
salta che ci vede che ci sente e invece
ognuno di noi è diverso ma È
quell'essere diverso che rende tutti di
noi unici e belli per quello che siamo
perché se tutti sapessimo fare le stesse
cose e se tutti noi non sapessimo fare
le stesse cose non si andrebbe mai
avanti ma rimarremmo tutti piatti tutto
uguale E adesso la sedia è diventata la
mia compagna di vita che mi permette di
essere qua mi permette di raccontarvi
questa cosa e mi permette di fare
qualsiasi cosa perché oggi la mia vita è
bella la mia vita è divertente è un po'
frenetica però mi diverto mi piace L'ho
scelta l'ho cercata l'ho ricalcolata e
la sto vivendo altrove è per me è stata
la soluzione è stata la soluzione perché
quando percorri una strada che non ti
porta più a niente ma c'è
un'interruzione
Allora devi essere in grado di cambiare
strada di cambiare strada ma avere
sempre in mente i tuoi obiettivi E così
per me è stato avevo i miei obiettivi e
sono riuscita a raggiungerli ma non da
sola perché da soli io credo che non si
arrivi da nessuna parte la mia famiglia
i miei fratelli i miei genitori i miei
amici mi sono stati sempre sempre vicino
non mi hanno mai detto di no non puoi
fare le cose ma troviamo il modo di
farle E questo troviamo il modo di farle
mi ha permesso di raggiungere tantissimi
obiettivi loro non mi hanno mai nascosto
la verità pensate che quando io mi sono
svegliata
dall'anestesia ancora non me lo ricord
ricordavo bene quindi me l'hanno
raccontata questa cosa ho chiesto alla
mamma Mamma posso tornare a saltare la
mia priorità era saltare neanche
camminare perché è quello che mi piaceva
fare e mi ha detto No Giulia non salti e
non cammini Mi sono girata dall'altra
parte
e adesso il ricalcolare È all'ordine del
giorno vi faccio un esempio io mi sono
fatta male che avevo 16 anni era il 2000
ehm 16 anni volevo prendere la patente
del 125 volevo la moto ma ovviamente non
potevo più prendere la patente per la
moto e cosa ho fatto ho deciso di
prenderla per il Quad il Quad quattro
ruote puoi farlo fa in motorizzazione a
Parma ma nessuno sa come fare perché è
la prima volta che succede che una
persona paraplegica chiede di fare la
patente del 125 e quindi inizia mia
mamma a cercar di capire come fare
questa cosa finché un ingegnere della
motorizzazione si prende la
responsabilità di dire la patente alla
Giulia la faccio io e così è stato
ricalcola è stato anche quando io
pensavo che il trampolino sarebbe stata
Il mio sport e in realtà adesso Il nuoto
è diventato la mia vita ho ricalcolato
ho ricalcolato perché ho scelto di
nuotare perché in acqua non hai confini
in acqua non hai barriere in acqua è la
prima volta dove io ho capito veramente
cos'era il mio nuovo corpo il peso delle
mie gambe cosa volesse dire non
camminare cosa volesse dire non sentire
le gambe perché in acqua non sei
appoggiato a niente né a un letto né a
una sedia sei solo tu il tuo corpo e
l'acqua e in acqua è dove quest'anno
dopo 13 anni da quando stavo preparando
il mondiale di trampolino ho vinto il
mondiale di
nuoto
altrove altrove Sì ma voglio dire Sono
sempre io sono una persona Sono sempre
io è il titolo che ho voluto dare al mio
libro per
incuriosire per andare altrove rispetto
a quello che noi già conosciamo voi
adesso mi vedete qui seduta Ma chissà
quante domande avete Chissà quante
domande avete Ma magari avete paura a
farle paura di farmi del male paura che
la domanda sia sciocca e invece no la
curiosità è la nostra forza e altrove Sì
ma non sempre perché io credo che la
felicità sia dentro di noi
non sono le cose delle volte possono
essere le medaglie Sì a farci felici a
farmi felice ma la medaglia è un
oggetto quello che ci sta dietro è
quello che veramente fa la felicità
Perché la medaglia se io la posso
condividere Allora sì che ha un valore
questa medaglia
e in conclusione quello che io vi voglio
dire è che sicuramente gli imprevisti le
cadute quello che noi non ci
aspetteremmo
capitano capitano Tutti i giorni
all'ordine del giorno anche se noi non
ce li andiamo a cercare e quindi bisogna
cercare la strada altrove magari sarà
sicuramente un cammino diverso da quello
che noi avevamo in mente da quello che
noi avevamo programmato di seguire Ma
questo percorso che noi cerchiamo
altrove per arrivare al nostro obiettivo
Perché noi dobbiamo arrivare arare al
nostro obiettivo e noi vogliamo arrivare
al nostro obiettivo è questo percorso
che abbiamo cercato altrove che abbiamo
voluto
percorrere che ci ha portato al nostro
obiettivo ma ricordandoci sempre di
essere noi stessi sia qui sia altrove
ovunque sto
[Applauso]
sia
di